the ground begins to tremble through
massive engines war to life
billowing clouds exhaust and in a
blinding pillar of fire
a mighty Voyager leaves the earth behind
to explore the vast universe among the
stars
launching a rocket into space is one of
humankind's crowning achievements
although they come in many different
shapes and sizes all Rockets are
propelled by engines that produce thrust
the Rockets that launch into space are
made up of four major systems based on
function the structural system makes up
the frame that holds a rocket together
and consists of the cylindrical body
nose cone and fins next the propulsion
system takes up the most amount of space
and includes the rocket engine fuel and
oxidizer the payload system depends on
each mission and consists of anything a
rocket is carrying into space like a
spacecraft satellite or human being
lastly the guidance system is made up of
radars and computers that provide
stability for the rocket and control
maneuvers in flight in order to launch
into space all four of these rocket
systems must work together to overcome
the force of gravity the launch begins
when the Rockets propulsion system
starts to generate a massive amount of
thrust thrust is the force produced by
burning fuel as exhaust gases escape
through the engine once the rocket
generates more thrust than its own
weight it lifts into the air to begin
its power descent during this phase of
the flight the weight of the rocket will
constantly change as fuel continues to
burn off as a result most space bound
rockets use a technique called staging
to reduce deadweight and increase
efficiency the method involves breaking
up a large rocket into two or three
smaller Rockets that fall away at
different stages of the launch as the
rocket continues into orbit its
sophisticated guidance system maintains
balance and steers to keep the flight
trajectory on track at the correct
altitude and speed the upper stage
engine cuts off completing the Rockets
journey from
surface into orbit long before blasting
into space rockets were used here on
earth as early as the 13th century the
first known rockets were introduced by
the Chinese and 12 32 ad these fire
arrows were used to fight against
invading armies and were made by
attaching fireworks packed with
gunpowder to long arrows by the 16th
century the use of rockets for amusement
had spread from Asia to Europe where
they gained popularity and elaborate
firework displays at celebrations and
festivities during the following
centuries the work of scientists like
Isaac Newton and his laws of motion
began to greatly increase knowledge into
the forces behind rocketry and how to
control them and by the end of the 18th
century military forces around the world
began to apply these new scientific
understandings to the battlefield
transforming the earlier crewed rockets
into powerful weapons of war however the
true dawn of space rocketry began in the
early 20th century
thanks to massive technological
improvements in rocket science and
Aeronautics by the 1950s the stage was
set for the modern space age and
development began on sophisticated
launch vehicle systems like the Atlas
rocket family which launched America's
first astronaut into orbit the titan
rockets which were behind the pivotal
Gemini missions during the space race
and the Saturn rocket family which
includes the largest and most
powerful rocket ever successfully
launched the mighty Saturn five standing
as high as a 36 story building and
weighing more than 3,000 tons this
behemoth was used to launch the Apollo
missions to the moon since the beginning
of human history adventurers have looked
to the skies and dreamt of touching the
Stars and today innovations in rocketry
are opening up possibilities to launch
astronauts farther into space than ever
before whether our sights are set on the
moon Mars or beyond the future of
rocketry and space exploration is only
just blasting off
[Music]
you
[Music]